happy holidays everybody I know
somebody's about to jump out of this
yeah I know that's what it is yeah
hasblah yeah could you imagine
bergy no that's the other kid no
hasblood's like uh I honestly I don't
know what he
I can't like do an impression of him
[Laughter]
do you like Hezbollah Hezbollah yeah
yeah oh what am I saying wrong I mean
Miss Bula yeah how could I like if he
came out of here right now I'd be so so
fired up yeah
or maybe it's just a big ASMR board
sorry
I mean we're supposed to be opening it
yeah eventually so can we open it what
do you think it is as someone's in here
dude I know I feel like there's
someone is definitely in here yeah I
[ __ ] hate this
it's Jake Paul in there I know it
now if I were to start kicking this
would that be a problem
[Laughter]
going Goblin mode I see hey [ __ ] off
that's our plaque
laughs
[Laughter]
that scared the sh even though we even
though we called it like literally three
seconds before it happened that still
got me so hard hey yo I was like this
I think my foot jumped just a little
[Laughter]
you know the image I have in my head
and then
just
God damn
oh my God remember that was they came
out at the right time the Grinch left
their phone
it's also funny that whoever that was
they were clearly scared yes yes
you were like what happens if I start
kicking this like no no no no no no no
no no
surprise don't get the [ __ ] out of here
damn dude happy Holidays happy holidays
well
I got you something did you yeah
it's the surfboard again no no no wait
hold up we got more gifts though
yeah I got you something too yeah
oh hold on let's get them
priced to Noel from Zach
to Cody from Zach
should we open these at the same time
I feel like it might be similar I have a
feeling it's like I'm with stupid or
something like that
rip on this I can't get a grip
there we go I got it what is this now
what is this
cool dude
[Laughter]
yeah you go for it you no no don't say
it don't say it that's it that's it
foreign
what is this
yeah if you can't see right now Cody's
holding up um it's a golf blanket
it's got to be the lamest gift I've ever
seen
um
thank you Zach
um this is going right to Goodwill
[Laughter]
not sick Zach's gift to me is pretty
interesting
um
I guess yeah he's giving me the best way
uh for him to take a little piece of me
home with him
the books the book that says cooking
with semen how is that real
yeah I don't know
that's a great gift yeah that's funny oh
there's nothing inside
oh there's nothing inside it's fake yeah
damn
it says I kind of thought it would have
been real like somebody to have made
something like this right
and if so we should find it
okay and then he got he got me a little
uh
oh that's sick that's weird you got a
picture of me
on an apron
interesting Zach by the way I like this
I like this blanket I like that it's
kind of like snarky
it says okay us golfer on it oh wait
guys how could I forget the um penis
shaped
[Music]
charcuterie charcuterie board well that
that's Zack's paycheck right there he
couldn't afford the rest of that right
ball oh he has one ball oh so it's
Zach's pain
this has one and a half balls though
that's good yeah
no this is this is a great gift dude
I'll get right away I'm making you that
cake
who's this takes a lot of balls to golf
the way I do not in your case
sorry Zach thank you Zach I appreciate
it
love you is that for me yeah okay to
chody every time Zach plays golf I
wonder if that's like a visualization of
his cancer
just sending one away
oh Jesus
all right that was that was good it's
just saying cancer explicitly makes it
feel a little heavier you know yeah
well he feels a lot lighter now
to Jody from another snowman oh
good a fellow
Snowman
snowman oh right yeah yeah
cold what
yes sure yeah
that's what it means
another man with rocks for teeth
yeah
who Who's the I don't know who it is
what who's the fellow snowman oh I don't
know but it's I think it's a cocaine
reference no isn't it nah
the [ __ ]
sorry I can't I have plans with my cat
who got me this I have no clue
I'm wearing the [ __ ] out of this shirt
though
know that all right this goes crazy yeah
that is pretty bad
who got me that sorry guys I'm a little
a little joked out I'm I'm tired from
our [ __ ] Wicked holiday party last
night
speaking of hitting balls yeah seriously
we ding some schmeters yeah dude
yeah you're hitting some pissers yeah
they were slight yeah you know so was
Ryan
this one's from Walid
oh my God it's Anthrax no just kidding
that was a race joke
uh now everyone gets it
those people don't do that what the [ __ ]
is this dude
is this a gag ball
oh it's
[Laughter]
[Music]
he wants me to train for my YouTube
boxing event
you got to punch this thing yeah I would
open more gifts but
sorry
I got I got some plans
look at that
that's what it's worth
it's a nut trainer
you're supposed to
that's what you're supposed to get it to
yeah yeah
[Laughter]
stroke trainer
ding ding ding ding ding oh